joining me this week is a CNN
contributor the managing director of skd
Knickerbocker media relations firm and
an optimist according to her Twitter bio
Hilary Rosen welcome to the Rubin report
hey how are you I'm good so you're an
optimist I know if it's said on Twitter
then it has to be true it's tough being
an optimist these days isn't it you know
I've lived in Washington so much longer
than i can really even admit but it's
like over 35 years and this town will
suck the life out of you like literally
like bodily suck it out of you and so
you know I've lived through the Reagan
years here I lived through the bush
years then the you know the second Bush
years I've and yet there's something
about it that um keeps me believing that
the next person is gonna make it better
and you know honestly living through
Barack Obama has had its moments so I'm
an optimist you're an optimist is this a
prescription drug related thing possibly
it a drug free there are three drug free
all right very good well well mostly
drug free yeah fair enough and whatever
it is I'm okay we don't test me notice
all right so you are a hillary supporter
your name is Hillary you've got one else
she's got to you are very Clinton
supporter I my audience is all over the
place which I'm very proud of so I know
you're gonna get a certain amount of
hate so I'm just giving you that's a
trigger warning for you or bring it on
or something like that so before we get
into Hillary though cuz that'll be the
easy part for you why do you not like
Donald J Trump you know it's funny
because I had this moment today so have
you paid attention to the you know the
Facebook live thing that they're doing
well I saw I saw a little bit of it mr.
sure mr. um tech right so I I literally
went to post that I thought that the
Trump campaigns Facebook live Daily Show
was a brilliant idea and
I kind of went back and forth Oh should
I not compliment him is that a bad thing
to do like well that will people think
then that I think that Hillary should do
a facebook like I just uh oh my god
you're so [ __ ] overthinking this oh
but so um the the you know I like
Kellyanne Conway as a person I'm sure
I'm gonna get hate mail from our
democratic friends on that so I thought
it was a good idea as a person I find
him an unbearable narcissist I always
have found him to be boorish you know
it's not a coincidence that the only
congressional district in New York State
that Donald Trump lost in the primary is
the one that he lives in not a
coincidence like the people who know him
best like him the least so I'd like to
that is a fact you're not making it up I
will grant you that fact it's a fact
right he lost that congressional
district the what he lost his
neighborhood no they did his neighbors
didn't vote for him um so you know I
could come up with one or two nice
things about him I do think that how
much his kids love him it's a good thing
you know so i agree with Hillary on that
I do think that anyone who can make a
business out of just using his name
which is really what his business has
been the last several years just using
his name um has to have some cessful as
my grandmother would say um but I don't
think it's particularly helpful for
anyone else because you know the average
still working at worker laid off in
ohio's not going to be able to create a
business out of his name um so I I'm
puzzled by by the affection for Trump's
business business skills but I just find
him to be kind of a terrible person yeah
so let's back up and start with what you
first said which is interesting about
the facebook live post and you were good
upon us because I suspect what you were
saying is that you were gonna post
something not necessarily praising Trump
but saying that this idea is interesting
right right anyway we're not we're not
allowed to do that anymore in this sort
of hyper partisan world so you know I I
did it anyway because I'm I don't really
live by hyper-partisan rules but I did
go through this kind of process over
whether it's okay or not to just to have
that kind of civil analytical
conversation so as someone on the left
as a as a liberal or progressive a
progressive or liberal doesn't even
matter to you yes what one of those both
of those organs for myself am what would
I'm a capitalist tool with a progressive
activist heart yeah that that's nice so
so as that does that dishearten you that
you know when you post something on your
own Facebook page that obviously are
these are your fans or your friends
these are people who know Hilary rose
and they know your politics that even by
posting I you know Trump this TV idea is
kind of interesting orgies using
Facebook and inappropriate that even
that's going to bring hate from the left
which is supposed to be the tolerance
I'd that must drive you crazy like
there's so many things about this
election that drive me crazy we you know
civility has become a partisan issue on
kind of both sides right to say
something like all of a sudden if you
say um I like Kellyanne Conway she's a
good person all of a sudden it's like
what are you talking about she's an evil
person or if you say actually you
shouldn't um want to ban all Muslims
that's you know not a good thing to say
you're so partisan you're so against
Tromso like these kind of basic niceties
that you were kind of brought up to
imagine would be the right way to live
every day all of a sudden it's caught up
in this sort of partisan whirlwind it's
a little frustrating I'm very proud that
I'm called a libtard and a member of the
all right every day like I think I that
says something you know a little tart
we're gonna worry man come from like
that's the best they could come up with
libtard now I get libtard on a [ __ ]
serve ative I'm a member of the all
right I'm a white nationalist you know
it's it's a lot yeah oh you are all
those things and I'm ashamed vote for it
I should have told you before you agreed
to do
show occasion all right so let's let's
talk about Hillary though because I've
found that for me at least in the online
space that I live in it's been easier
for me to find people if the online
space that you're in right now I know
you do the mainstream thing but you're
you're in the online world right now
just imagining you like living in your
little box just a tiny teeny tiny
dial-up thing ready ops in the Hollywood
Hills not in the Hills I hear you but
I'm able to find more passionate Trump
supporters that I've had better
exchanges with then then Hillary people
the Hillary people have either been like
connected to the campaign somehow or
they or the I sense that a lot of
Hillary people are voting for her but
grudgingly so someone that as someone
that's not voting for her begrudging Lee
can you sell me on Hillary Clinton yeah
I hear a lot I hear people say that
Hillary voters are unenthusiastic but I
meet a lot of enthusiastic Hillary
voters so i'm not sure where the
disconnect is coming from I think you
can look at people and sort of
categorize them bite by ages and I just
had a couple of women in my office
earlier today one of them was a
millennial and late you know so they
don't she didn't know the Clintons of
the you know 70s and 80s the sort of you
know progressive middle-class Clinton's
right you know before they became a
member of the elite class like the rest
of us have now um she you know so but
would she really keyed in I'm she's like
oh my god Hillary Clinton talking about
sexual harassment and making this be an
important issue in this campaign has
totally excited my friends and I because
this has been a real issue for us it was
an issue for us a few years ago in
college it's still an issue for us and
nobody else has ever talked about it in
public life like that's a really big
thing and so she's enthusiastic and for
a whole other set of reasons for that
you know killer is giving voice to 44
young women
and yet for someone like me who you know
was worked and no worked with her known
her for a long time I remember when she
you know made sure that after that
disheartening defeat on health care she
came back and didn't give up and pass
the children's health insurance law that
is you know helped a lot of kids to this
day so like I know that kind of
pragmatic thoughtful engaging really
wonky side of her that is rooted in
policy I i love that side of her uh I
also have but I know kind of the girls
girls side of her that the one who at
lunch remembers you know who you're
dating in your family and the last time
she talked to you and you know I just
saw her recently actually at an event
and the first thing she said to me was
I'm like you know I've been thinking
about you because you know our friends
husband has cancer and are you you know
I wish I could do more you you know
taking care of her um you know that's
Hillary that's that's who she is so do
you think it's partly that because of
the over-the-top caricature that Trump
basically is that people are just sort
of whether you hate it or you love it
there's a certain attraction to that
it's clickable it's it's easy to
understand what it is where the word you
use pragmatic with Hillary it just sort
of seems boring or whatever maybe maybe
perfectly great and maybe what you want
out of a leader but that it may be just
isn't flying for the 2016 twitter age um
well I think the answer the short answer
is yes but I think one thing we have to
be proud of with uh Hillary in this
campaign is I think she has gone at
Trump with a little more intensity and
maybe a little more relish than people
thought she would personally that was a
conscious decision on her part because
she felt has felt like when other people
have gone after him earlier in the
campaign season they didn't get as much
attention for it and basically she had
the bully pulpit and she needed to use
it um having said that the thing that
she has stayed pretty consistent on I
think is that she started out this
campaign with a lot of wonky policy
papers with a lot of positions with deep
you know not two or three point plans
but 10-point plans on virtually every
subject and I stayed there has stayed
there doing roundtable events on all
sorts of subjects has you know
consistently we just saw it in the last
debate when someone was talking about
Obamacare it didn't get much attention
but Hillary actually recited the top
five you know benefits of Obamacare and
why it mattered and what we would lose
if we actually repeal that whereas Trump
was just like I gotta get rid of it it's
a disaster it's a disaster you know he
he didn't even really know the actual
policies that it mattered in the in the
legislation so I I think she has
consistently been that person this is a
really long run on answer but to wrap
that up it's just she started this
campaign with goals of what she wanted
to do as president I think she's ending
up this campaign you know outlining
those same goals yeah so the Obamacare
one is an interesting play because I
have no doubt that she knows her stuff
inside and out I've said it on the show
many times but in it as an example with
Obamacare you know we just heard in the
last couple days that there are these
double-digit rate hikes and things like
that so it's it's weird because on one
hand she has to defend the parts of
Obamacare that are obviously are working
and then at the same time people see the
headline you know they look back and you
know they hear Obama saying if you like
your parent who can keep it we know that
wasn't exactly true we certain hikes
weren't going to be true then people see
the headline which i'm sure i haven't
seen drudge today but I'm sure it's the
lead thing you know double-digit
increases so she's sort of caught by
being part of the system where she has
to defend something and attack it at the
same time where Trump doesn't have to
he's outside so he can kind of say
he wants right um well he says she's
caught but I'm not sure that's the
construct that she I think she is
articulating for people to benefit no
question and if you're one of those 20
million people who now have health
insurance you really don't want your
presidential candidate out there saying
we got to get rid of this thing so I
don't I don't think she feels caught
well what about the people that are
upset about the increases right well
that's I'm saying I think I think you
have to be honest and recognize that
there are multiple audiences hear that
that feel differently about this law you
know I'm a small business owner health
care costs have gone up a lot in the
last couple of years but before
Obamacare passed our health care costs
were skyrocketing so I this law didn't
solve all the problems in healthcare and
because there was a very strategic
decision to keep our health care system
in the private sector to keep it
relatively competitive among companies
you know that that you're not going to
you're not going to be able to dictate
what all of the price increases are what
all the plans are and and how the
outcomes are
you